you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
rising energy costs fuel a rise in
inflation and the cost of living crisis
a major oil spill in peru which
authorities say was caused by the tonga
volcano eruption
president biden sets out new plans to
tackle wildfires in the u.s as he marks
one year in office
and a warning that future leaders need
more help to deal with the consequences
of climate change we look at what to
expect in the 2040s and 2050s
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
a cost of living crisis is expected to
take grip on the uk in the coming weeks
with inflation now at 5.4 percent that's
the highest rate since march 1992.
one of the main factors of this rising
cost of living is oil and gas prices
feeding into our energy bills and the
government is now scrambling to prevent
an estimated annual household increase
of hundreds of pounds but the government
is also committed to net zero targets
set out last year as part of cop 26.
so how much is tackling one crisis going
to impact the other and could green
targets in fact help the costs come down
for families well joining me now is our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter so hannah
what does the cost of living crisis mean
for green targets
well everybody's thinking hard about
cash or lack of it and that has meant
that a potentially calamitous fault line
is emerging within the conservative
party as if boris johnson didn't have
enough to worry about you'll remember
that the net zero target to reduce
carbon emissions to net zero by 2050 is
enshrined in law it was an important
part of the conservative party's
manifesto but now there is a big row
brewing over it the office for budget
responsibility uh thinks the total
investment needed to get to net zero
carbon emissions by 2050 could run up to
nearly one and a half trillion pounds
that will of course they say reduce uh
or produce huge savings well over a
trillion pounds you know as a result but
an awful lot of that spending they say
is going to have to happen in the next
decade if the uk is going to hit its
targets
which means that this issue is now being
weaponized
we've got on the one hand a group of
some 20 mps called the net zero security
or scrutiny group the net zero scrutiny
group led by people like steve baker mp
a serial rebel and brexiteer who's now
set his sights on this issue
and he is saying that it could be bigger
than brexit in terms of its ability to
divide the country he's even invoked in
an interview with sky news the poll tax
riots he has said that the government
needs to dig for more oil and gas in the
north sea to increase its domestic
supply and to scrap green levees on
energy bills to ease the pain
for ordinary people and he has told me
that uh he's been in charge of
rebellions over brexit and over covert
but this one in relation to the net zero
targets he says is the fastest growing
and has got an awful lot of traction
and then on the other side you've got a
much larger group of green conservative
mps the conservative environment network
very much aligned with the prime
minister now some of them are just
dismissing the net zero scrutiny group
saying that is an organization of people
who are kind of going perilously close
to climate being climate deniers they're
populists just looking to score
political points but there are those who
say steve baker is a very good organizer
we should worry about this this argument
that is going to land with ordinary
people and they are trying to make their
own argument aligned with boris johnson
that the green revolution represents a
huge opportunity it is actually the
answer they say to rising energy costs
in particular because investing in
renewables will eventually bring those
prices down and give the uk a degree of
energy sovereignty uh that it that it
needs
now the eruption of the underwater
volcano in the south pacific nation of
tonga sent a huge ash cloud into the
skies above and prompted a tsunami which
has wiped out entire villages but the
impacts don't stop there more than 10
000 kilometers away in peru the waves
from the volcano have caused an
environmental disaster with an estimated
6 000 barrels of oil spilled into the
water which is rich in marine life
we need to declare a state of emergency
throughout this whole sector so the
armed forces can come in and help with
their personnel and equipment
as a human being i can tell you it's
truly been a tremendous heartbreak to
watch the birds and sea lions dying
well crystal chesky is the marine
governance initiative of the peruvian
society for environmental law and joins
us from close to where the oil spill
happened north of lima in peru
so welcome to you tell us more about
this spill
then just how bad is it and how is it
affecting where you are
um it's been absolutely devastating i
have never seen environmental disaster
from this close um
with this kind of scale we have at least
1 000 fishers here in the place where i
am right now in ancon who have lost
their livelihoods at the moment and will
probably be affected for many years to
come because the marine environment is
completely polluted
um we need to stop the spread of that of
this oil slick
right now and when you start cleaning up
um the beaches and the waters that have
been contaminated on top of that there
need to be some really deep
investigations into what happened
because the whole world knew that the
tonga
about the tonga eruption but why didn't
the peruvian authorities issue a tsunami
warning like other countries did and why
did repsol continue with the transfer of
oil from its refinery to a large oil
tanker despite knowing that um these
these waves were going to arrive um at
our coast so there are many open
questions and um
the people responsible uh need to be
held to justice and
what we need to do is um ensure that the
people who are most affected who are the
most vulnerable the fishers and the
people who live off tour of sea tourism
here and are compensated um
okay um adequately okay well christelle
chesky we appreciate your time thanks
very much indeed
thank you
now volcanoes can have devastating
impacts on the environment around them
but what are the long-term impacts on
climate change
it was kind of like bombs were just
going off around the place so we knew
that something catastrophic had happened
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well now for some of the day's other
climbing news and the german chancellor
olaf schultz says he wants germany's
presidency of the g7 to be the nucleus
of an international climate club
he spoke at the world economic forum
today alongside u.s climate envoy john
kerry who called for leaders to be more
ambitious on climate targets
climate change will limit where the
winter olympics can be held in the
future a new study has found researchers
at the university of waterloo in canada
say unless greenhouse gas emissions are
drastically reduced only one of the
previous 21 hosts sapporo in japan could
reliably stage the games again by the
end of the century
the bible administration has unveiled a
10-year plan to combat the country's
worsening seasonal wildfires president
joe biden is marking his first year in
office but has faced criticism for
failing to get members of his own party
to commit to the spending bill that
would have funded his climate pledges
and we'll be talking more about whether
joe biden's climate policies have gone
far enough when i'm joined by the chief
executive of the climate group helen
clarkson and the guardian columnist
george monbiot shortly
now then let's take a look at our data
dashboard now where we can show you the
power mix in the uk right now and you
can see that coal is making up 0.3
and gas 43.5
and you can see also how much is coming
from renewable energy like wind and
power that's 35.1 there let me also show
you this number here now this is the co2
emissions being released into the
atmosphere globally and as you can see
that number they're ticking up all the
time and it's those co2 emissions that
are of course fueling climate change and
a new study by the institute for public
policy research is warning that
millennial leaders likely to be the
decision makers in the future need help
preparing for the consequences of
biodiversity loss in the 2040s and 2050s
so with an average of 1.2 degrees of
warming the world is already
experiencing more heat waves and record
temperatures were set last summer in
canada and in sicily now by around 2050
the ipcc predicts that extreme heat
events will become more than five times
more likely so
heat waves that historically happened
once a decade are likely to happen every
other year
now extreme heat leads directly to
increased wildfires and those in
australia in 2019 and 20 were attributed
to climate change and those events will
be four times more likely to occur if we
reach two degrees of warming by 2050
according to the world weather
attribution group
now huge floods have already become more
frequent a study found that devastating
flooding in germany in july last year
was made up to nine times more likely
because of climate change and that's
because the atmosphere is holding more
water as the world heats up and if it
continues to warm we could see more
intense floods nearly twice as
frequently
so the question for future leaders is
how to plan for and adapt to the world's
rising temperatures and what defenses
can be put in place to protect us
so now we know what future generations
need to prepare for but how are we
preparing for climate change in the next
few decades well joining us after the
break to discuss that will be the chief
executive of the climate group helen
clarkson and george monbiot
environmentalist and guardian columnist
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with chief
executive of the climate group helen
clarkson and the guardian columnist
george monbiot so very good evening to
both of you good to see though
so president biden has been in office
for a year and he arrived on a wave of
optimism on climate action one of his
first acts was to rejoin the paris
climate accord after donald trump left
it and he soon announced ambitious
policy measures to cut emissions and
rebuild the economy with climate central
to every policy but his progress has
been stymied by politics according to
one analyst he over-promised and
under-delivered so let's find out what
our guests make of his record so far
helen he did come into office a year ago
with climate change one of his main four
priorities so what's your take on it has
he delivered
yeah you know at the outset i think um
it was very good he very quickly uh came
back into the paris agreement he gave
that certainty that businesses and
states in the u.s were looking for and
others who played such a critical role
over the four years where we had
president trump he was obviously very
antithetical to the agenda that was all
good and we ran an event uh alongside
biden had a leadership summit last april
we ran something called u.s climate
action week alongside that and i was
really impressed with members of his
administration coming out really
understanding uh you know the brief they
really got it you could see that they
really internalized this and were very
very serious about it so that's all good
and then we saw john kerry go out across
the year and do a lot of diplomacy so i
think there's a lot to praise that i
think the the issue is you mentioned it
not having that domestic legislation
there's some in the infrastructure bill
that's mostly about adaptation but in
terms of the ndc they've set and the us
hitting that most of that is sitting in
the buildback better uh legislation
which hasn't gone through it's delayed
and i think that's problematic because
we know that this presidency is time
limited we don't know what's coming next
a lot of that needs to get in place now
and as far as that diplomacy goes
without that legislation you can see the
kind of eyebrows
of other world leaders going up so i
think those are the bits that that
really are holding them back
well yes it's obviously some problems
george but what do you make of his
record because as as was being pointed
out there by helen a white house office
of domestic climate policy
john kerry being appointed to go and out
and reassert u.s leadership on the
global stage a handful of new
regulations promising major investments
in clean energy and resetting u.s
targets i mean
do you welcome what he's set out so far
well the crucial thing with climate is
not so much the new things you do as the
old things you stop doing
so for instance leaving fossil fuels in
the ground it's absolutely crucial
and what have we seen unfortunately
quite the opposite we've seen
massive new leases for oil drilling
issued by the biden administration some
of them immediately after the climate
talks in in glasgow they basically went
down legally
to follow through on those aren't they
uh so i think upon them doesn't the
white house say they were legally
compelled to follow through on some of
that that's what they say and yeah they
lost a lawsuit that's what they say but
actually they had a whole series of
possible mechanisms they could have used
to fight that and to push back against
it and they failed to do that
but worse than that we now see a
succession of administration officials
going to the oil industry and saying
drill baby drill we want more domestic
output of oil and gas so will you please
deliver that for us and you know that
might sort of keep drivers
happy when they're paying for fuel at
the pump but that is absolutely
contrary to everything that biden says
he's doing on the climate and that's the
stuff that counts you can come up with
all sorts of wonderful policies you can
resign the paris agreement which is
great you know and he's done some
positive things like cancelling the
keystone xl pipeline but unless you are
actually prepared to leave fossil fuels
in the ground you undermine all that
good work that's the important thing
helen do you agree with that and to what
extent do you think that actually
it's it's his political opponents that
are blocking him it's not him he wants
to push through his build back better
climate plans but um he's being blocked
yeah i mean of course look i agree i
think that's really critical point about
you know i think we see this around the
world there's always like well we'll
just have one last coal mine we'll just
see that one and then we'll get on with
it and so the seriousness comes as
george says about like when do you what
do you stop doing how quickly do you
stop doing that i think of course it's
true about his political opponents and
we just got to keep the pressure on the
administration to
um to do what they're saying what
they're going to do and also to make
sure that the the way is forward for
places like california we do a lot of
work with california and i think it's
been really important that you know the
federal government is getting out of the
way of california so it can pass vehicle
standards which will make a difference
there but yes of course that that point
about leaving uh leaving fuel in the
ground and i'm really worried about you
know globally not just the us but what's
happening on gas and the fact that we're
all sort of somehow buying into this
kind of story about gas and sorry to cut
in just we haven't got much time but i
do want it to get that kind of
international feel as well george
because if the us doesn't meet its
targets
how much does that send out the wrong
message to other countries they're
putting pressure on
to meet their own
it's catastrophic really because still
people look to the us for leadership
rightly or wrongly wrongly on climate i
think because its record has been pretty
appalling but if even biden can't
deliver then other countries will say
well what's the point of us doing it
what's the point of us doing it if the
us isn't doing it and already we see
worldwide and almost perfect circle of
finger pointing everyone as saying it's
it's their responsibility they're going
to do it they're to blame
and it goes right the way around the
world and comes back to where you
started and it doesn't solve this
massive catastrophe okay so a lot of
pressure for on him to deliver on his
promises i guess okay let's move on to
our second topic shall we because
earlier we painted a picture of what the
world might look like not too long from
now if global warming continues along a
trajectory that looks all too likely and
a report warns today of the huge
challenge that'll pose for future
leaders
so helen the next generation of leaders
potentially face a very different world
don't they so how should current leaders
prepare for that
yeah i read the report and i don't
disagree with a word in it of course the
world's gonna look very different my
worry again is it's almost like that
finger-pointing piece is i don't want
current leaders distracted by sort of
sitting down and pondering how they get
their future generations ready we need
to think about what we're doing right
right now and i think what currently
does need to be thinking about is
massive changes to way that they operate
how do we really embrace the urgency the
scale of change that we need and i think
they should be thinking more along the
lines of how do we get those voices into
boardrooms now than you know do we do we
just push this off onto the next
generation and say that it's about
preparing them so i don't disagree with
that report but i i just worry that
again it's about pushing a problem onto
someone else well yes in georgia isn't
that the nature of short-term political
cycles that inevitably politicians will
be thinking about the here and now and
what voters think about spending money
well it shouldn't be like that and and
in fact i think programs like yours are
very important in trying to refocus them
and say look you know you will be judged
your long-term legacy is going to be
this because this is the most important
issue on earth this is the biggest
challenge humanity has ever faced if you
get this wrong everything else you do is
dust it's completely irrelevant because
there won't be any legacy
at all if we don't um tackle this huge
overwhelming existential crisis and you
know i don't think all politicians are
completely venal and completely
short-sighted and completely stupid
about issues like this i think it's
about the pressure they feel and at the
moment they're feeling pressure from
people saying oh our fuel bills are too
high and stuff they need to be feeling
more of the kind of pressure which we on
this program are trying to put on them
they need to be feeling more people
saying sorry you know we will judge you
on this this is the important thing
and then i think you know as some
politicians have done in the past
we will see people being more
statesmanlike taking that long-term view
putting aside their immediate short-term
interests for something more important
and very briefly helen public opinion if
you look at polls is shifting in favor
of action on climate change do you think
that is what will make the difference
that will put pressure on businesses
it'll put pressure on politicians and
and change will happen are you
optimistic
that is one source of optimism is and i
think this largely goes to the school
strikes and others who've raised that
voice and actually just pushing pressure
on their parents at home what are you
doing about this and sort of taking that
you know what george was just saying
there and domestic you know bringing it
domestically what are you doing about
this and we really see that with working
with business and government it's moving
from that remote thing of people out
there want this to actually
feeling that um that strong pressure
coming and i think we see the pole
shifting public opinion really has
changed and moved you see that even how
the media is covering things so
there's a grain of optimism there but
we've got to get that sense of this is
about changes that we do right right now
that are going to make that difference
over the long term horizon okay i'm
going to leave on the word optimism even
if there's only a grain of optimism
we'll we'll leave it there hello
clarkson george mobile thanks both very
much indeed thank you
well tomorrow i can be joined by a
member on the climate change the
committee on climate change dame julia
king and leading expert in carbon
footprinting and director at the small
world consulting mike berners-lee but
for today that's all from us thanks for
joining us
[Music]